oh man what's the flying gonna be like
in this
yeah no problem Daniel I mean it's free
to play might as well try it out I'm
normally not a big mobile game player
but if you're a Wizarding World fan at
all I mean so far I am I am super
impressed
I mean like
I'm enjoying this way more than I
thought I would try flying outside the
Great Hall yo Dylan oh my gosh how'd you
find me dude there's Dylan you guys
yo
it's your boy Dylan
see this is why I'm so excited for these
types of games man I mean we've been
saying a Harry Potter MMO would do
incredibly well
I meant like a you know a console PC
game
oh Dylan you just showing off now he's
just showing off look at this he's got
like some little eat what is this like a
little emote thing going
that is too cool
all right so I think we have to talk to
Robin about flying first hold out your
hand and hold to your broom
now climb on and when you're ready push
off the ground
ride okay
[Music]
yo jay-zt ZT
come on all right I accepted it
[Music]
swipe to adjust the camera all right
okay now how do we follow
drag to move release to stop
oh that actually feels
actually feels really nice
okay I'm not in control right now
look to the Horizon if you're ever
feeling scared
am I in control yet
no we're still not in control
oh Jenny you were there too
no way oh this is crazy you guys
how many people can you get together
with and go through the Forbidden Forest
to do the Forbidden Forest runs
because that I think is gonna be
a lot of fun to hop in with you guys
do you want to dance is it time to learn
that
I'm not controlling any of this you guys
I wasn't controlling any of that you're
the best
50. you could have 50 people in the
forest
my gosh that's amazing my only other one
was Kevin that's amazing
Lauren uh all you missed was uh we just
did our first flying and we saw Dylan
walking around
thanks Robin you're a great teacher
wanna go again
uh no thanks I'm good I want to see it
was fun but I want to see the other
things I don't know why I wasn't
controlling I don't know if that was on
purpose or what but I wasn't in control
of that I wish I
had wait sign in
sign in is not available yet complete
yearbook stories and enrollment deal
progress through yearbook stories to
claim up to 30 Ruby keys
foreign
get 10 pulls for only nine keys
oh I let you try out the card
dude I'm like I'm slightly overwhelmed
at all this I'm not gonna lie
now how do I get back to that other
thing
open your knapsack all right
oh camera
oh dude that's cool
[Music]
oh yeah yeah let's fly over here
dude this is basically like a photo mode
okay I want to turn it
oh my phone is getting really hot now
Anna where I've been playing for a while
maybe
like I want you to be able to see me in
the photo too
oh kind of like right there
right there right there right there
all right now let's see that says new
right there a filter
afternoon in the library oh this is so
cool
all right I'm just gonna go with the the
regular one
and then what are these
all my memories first time at the
dueling Club
and then our photos will show here all
right so how do I get rid of all the
menu
hi DUI there we go
wait I said hide UI
what is portrait mode oh it kind of
blurs out the background
oh that's perfect it takes it
automatically removes it
okay I want to download this
uh yes confirm
allow access
and then you could just tweet it out too
[Music]
that's really cool I like that
all right so now head to herbology and
then also augmenti
remember remember to search for pots and
chests you get gems and gold yeah I did
find a little uh random pot earlier
that I made sure to grab can you also
get them when you're flying around like
this too
yeah see now I'm fully in control
oh I got the Whomping wheel over here
all right
the Whomping Willows got me
the Whomping Willow
got Hagrid's Hut over here and then all
you guys are just like here in the world
I'm sorry I know many games have done so
I know many games have done this before
but I just can't get over the idea that
I'm like flying around and seeing you
guys in the world that is so cool we got
some people playing quidditch over here
question mark
wait what have I done
what what have I done
oh my goodness
it's actually really difficult
[Music]
this is actually really really difficult
come on
oh we're on a timer
come on no
goodness dude uh is it obvious that I
don't play mobile games very much there
we go we got it
I don't even know what we got for that
but that was cool
and then we got people like actually
playing quidditch over here or is it
just like a
I don't think these are real people I
think this is just a practice going on
see if it if it does the same thing
oh that turn right there
I don't know why I flew all the way back
I just don't want to break my momentum
turn
the last one go
there we go all right I don't want to do
that again I don't know if it's giving
me anything or not I phone's gonna die
soon I know it but I have backup hey
it's Neville
new okay and then we also have the
camera right there
it's so cool
that is so cool
all right so we got inspect and then
talk to Neville let's inspect first
oh right there there we go Draco that's
what Draco was talking about you gotta
be on the lookout for little things that
you can
interact with around the world
okay and then we would exit into the
castle right there
[Music]
all right Neville what's up hello I'm
glad you're here I could use your help
watering a few Professor Longbottom
it's so good to see you Neville
um sure
do you have a watering gun
oh lee just use the aguamenti charm
aquamenti
Ally I know it's a bit Advanced but
Professor Flitwick mentioned he was
going to introduce it earlier this year
here's your chance to practice
all right I'll give it a go
cast aguamenti on the sapling
right here
oh dude look
the bow truffles
cast aquamity on this wait did I not do
it right did I mess up Neville treated
you as a peace offering before he
decides to gouge out your eyes
[Music]
yes treat
quickly
quickly he needs a treat there's some
bow truck will feed me those old flower
pots that Hagrid dropped off earlier
careful though I found a few gnomes
hiding in the pots I got most of them
but there might be a few left
be careful okay
no way they got gnomes in this game too
all right inspect the pots I think we're
supposed to go
this way right here
let's see uh here's the feed
and also there he is
oh they look creepy they look more
creepy than the remember the ones in the
chamber Secrets video game
oh we gotta battle the Gnomes no way
all right gnomes let's go
let's go gnomes
defeat the Gnomes in the greenhouse
oh we only have one try using augmenti
on the Gnomes
uh let's hit these two right here
Clementi
oh wow it does really fast takes them
down quickly all right which way do you
want me to move you can move while
casting
oh you want me to go that way okay
oh and it keeps going
clutch clutch more gnomes have appeared
and let's get an inflate us on these two
right here
what do these guys do I haven't used
them yet
now you're in
Orange
the alpha gnome has a Pier defeated
oh we're about to get our our lightning
spell monster
yes
so this is our legendary
so you have to really like make sure
you're lining it up
the fact that you can move around with
aquaminty
hey static thank you so much for the
follow
oh it popped up behind my
house yes I'll accept your friend
request there
interact with the bow trickle at the
herbology classroom
right here is the bow struggle
I'm sorry about the world static
appreciate you subscribing to the
channel by the way
lets out a sound of satisfaction that
was quite a big treat I think you made a
friend for life
but do try to be more careful you never
know what might be lurking under the
next leaf
interact with the bull trickle yes
complete
oh it's dance club time you guys
you all were saying you couldn't wait
for me to get to that part
we're almost there
all right so yeah augmenti I feel like
it was pretty strong right there